DURING THE PANDEMIC.
JONATHAN SERRIE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
A LOT OF BACKLASH FOR TEXAS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT’S DECISION.
CALIFORNIA’S GOVERNOR DEMOCRAT
GAVIN NEWSOM CALLED IT RECKLESS.
NEWSOM HAS ORDERED SOME OF THE
NATION’S STRICTEST LOCKDOWNS.
ONE HEALTH OFFICIAL IN TEXAS IS
WARNING PEOPLE NOT TO CHANGE
THEIR BEHAVIOR JUST YET.
DESPITE THE IMPENDING REMOVAL
OF THE STATE MASK MANDATE WE
MUST CONTINUE WITH OUR
VIGILANCE WITH MASKING,
DISTANCING AND HAND WASHING.
KEN PAXTON TEXAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL JOINS ME NOW.
TALK WITH ME ABOUT MEETING THAT
BACKLASH WITH THE FACTS THAT
YOU IN TEXAS ARE WORKING WITH.
>> WHENEVER YOU DO SOMETHING
RELATED TO COVID YOU’LL GET
BACKLASH ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
NO ONE HAS DONE IT PERFECTLY
AND NO ONE KNEW HOW TO DO IT
PERFECTLY.
WHATEVER YOU DO YOU ALWAYS GET
CRITICISM.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS MOVED IN
THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT DIRECTION
WITH PUTTING THE DECISION IN
THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
MAKE THE DECISIONS ABOUT
THEMSELVES ABOUT THEIR OWN
LIVES.
LETTING BUSINESS OWNERS DECIDE
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
IF THEY WANT RESTRICTIONS THEY
CAN AND CONSUMERS CAN DECIDE IF
THEY WANT TO SHOW UP.
IT WAS A VERY GOOD DECISION AND
THE DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO.
>> Harris: I WANT TO THROW THIS
INTO THE MIX BECAUSE IT IS
ABOUT THE FACTS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC DEATHS PER
100,000 PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE,
TEXAS AND FLORIDA IS ABOUT 140
SIMILAR TO THE STATES WITH SOME
OF THE STRICTEST LOCKDOWNS IN
THE NATION, CALIFORNIA 132
DEATHS PER 100,000.
NEW YORK 163.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THOSE ARE JUST STATISTICS
AND FACTS ABOUT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
SO I THINK WHAT THAT SAYS IS
THIS IS A PANDEMIC THAT WAS
GOING THE SPREAD ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER AND THERE ARE THINGS WE
CAN DO TO PROTECT OURSELVES BUT
WE CAN’T PROTECT EVERYONE ALL
THE TIME AND IT IS GOING TO
SPREAD TO SOME DEGREE.
SO AS THE NUMBERS SHOW IT
REALLY HASN’T MADE THAT MUCH
DIFFERENCE WHICH WAY YOU’VE
GONE.
THAT’S ANOTHER GOOD REASON TO
LET PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK.
RON DESANTIS SAID IT WELL.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN WORK BY ZOOM
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SUFFERED ECONOMICALLY
AND MENTALLY BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO WORK.
>> Harris: THAT’S SO
INTERESTING.
FOR THOSE GOVERNORS AND
MUNICIPALITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
HAVE STRICTER LOCKDOWNS THE
FACTS BEAR OUT AND YOU ARE
SAYING THEY SHOW IT’S ABOUT THE
SAME IF YOU DON’T HAVE THOSE
REALLY STRICT LOCKDOWNS.
I WONDER WHEN THEY START TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
JUST A QUESTION.
>> HOPEFULLY SOON.
I DON’T WANT PEOPLE IN OTHER
STATES TO SUFFER, EITHER.
>> Harris: EXACTLY.
IT AFFECTS US ALL.
FOX IS CONFIRMING BIDEN’S NEW
BORDER POLICY HAS ALLOWED MORE
THAN 100 MIGRANTS RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES AFTER TESTING
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
AND THE TESTS ARE DONE IN
BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS AND AN
OFFICIAL THERE SAYS THE CITY
DOESN’T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
STOP THOSE MIGRANTS FROM
TRAVELING ANYWHERE WITHIN THE
U.S.
SOME MIGRANTS HAVE TOLD BORDER
AGENTS THEY’RE HEADED TO NEW
JERSEY, NORTH CAROLINA,
MARYLAND.
DHS IS WARNING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT AN
UNPRECEDENTED SURGE OF
UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT CHILDREN
SHOWING UP ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
HOWEVER, PRESIDENT BIDEN DENIES
THAT THERE IS EVEN A CRISIS.
>> ABOUT THE BORDER TODAY?
>> President Biden: YES, I DID.
>> WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
>> Harris: A LOT.
>> IS THERE A CRISIS?
>> Harris: FIRST OF ALL
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAXTON, I WANT
TO JUST GET YOUR PUSHBACK ON
THE CRISIS POINT OF THIS.
AGAIN JUST LOOKING AT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
>> YEAH, FROM DAY ONE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CAME OUT AND SAID HE
WASN’T GOING TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW AND WE SUED
HIM, MY BIGGEST CONCERN, ONE OF
MY BIGGEST CONCERNS WHAT ABOUT
THE HEALTH STATUS OF THE PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS?
WE WON’T KNOW IT.
IF WE DO WE AREN’T GOING TO
STOP THEM.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
NOW SUDDENLY IT IS NOT.
WE’LL LET PEOPLE COME INTO THE
COUNTRY THAT MAY HAVE COVID AND
SPREAD IT BACK INTO MY STATE
AND NEW JERSEY AND NORTH
CAROLINA LIKE YOU DISCUSSED.
IT IS A BIG ISSUE.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, I WANT TO
LEAN INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT,
THOUGH.
BECAUSE THE TIMING OF THIS
COULD NOT BE MORE PRECARIOUS
FOR YOUR STATE.
YOU ARE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
FOR AMERICANS IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS LETTING THE BUSINESSES
REGENERATE THEMSELVES, THOSE
THAT ARE POSSIBLY COMING BACK.
WE PRAY THEY ARE.
ALL OF THE THINGS AND LETTING
THAT PERSONAL FREEDOM.
THERE WILL BE SOME TALK ABOUT
MASK WEARING BUT ALL OF THAT AT
A TIME WHEN WE’RE LETTING ALL
THESE PEOPLE IN AND WE CAN
BARELY CHECK THEM.
>> I THINK IT’S IRRESPONSIBLE
ON THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT TO
LET THIS HAPPEN.
WE ALL KNOW THAT COVID IS AN
ISSUE AND TRIED TO DO OUR BEST
TO RESPOND TO IT.
WE PUT ALL KINDS OF
RESTRICTIONS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WE’RE LOOSENING UP RESTRICTIONS
TRYING TO GET BUSINESSES BACK
ON THEIR FEET AND THEN WE’LL
LET MORE COVID COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY?
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU EXPLAIN
THAT OTHER THAN TO SAY
ABSOLUTELY IRRESPONSIBLE ON THE
PART OF THE PRESIDENT FOR
LETTING THIS HAPPEN.
>> Harris: QUICKLY BEFORE WE
MOVE ON.
IT IS A CHOICE, THOUGH.
THESE ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO
ARE ALREADY HERE, THE DECISIONS
MADE IN TEXAS, THESE ARE PEOPLE
COMING FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES
AND WERE MAKING DECISIONS THAT
DON’T CORRELATE WITH THEM BEING
AMERICAN CITIZENS BECAUSE
THEY’RE NOT.
>> YOU’VE NAILED IT ON THE HEAD.
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
FIRST OF ALL THEY SHOULDN’T BE
HERE ANYWAY AND ALLOWED TO COME
ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY AREN’T SUPPOSED TO BE.
THE INJUNCTION THE PRESIDENT
HAS TO DEPORT THOSE PEOPLE.
WHETHER THAT IS HAPPENING WE’LL
SEE AS WE GO ALONG.
JUST THE NARRATIVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS PUTTING OUT THAT
IS SEEMINGLY INVITING PEOPLE TO
COME AND THE NUMBERS ARE
STARTING TO SHOW IT, IT CREATES
NOT JUST THE COVID RISK BUT
ALSO HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
DRUGS AND ALL KINDS OF CRIME
ISSUES THAT MY STATE NOW HAS TO
DEAL WITH.
>> Harris: THE ONES WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ALL ALONG.
DHS PROJECTS A RECORD BREAKING
117,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
WILL TRY TO CROSS INTO THE
UNITED STATES THIS YEAR
ILLEGALLY.
LAST YEAR THAT NUMBER WAS JUST
MORE THAN 33,000.
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS JUMP.
WHAT IS DRIVING IT?
>> I THINK IT’S THE PRESIDENT,
HIS ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY
SAYING YOU CAN COME HERE AND
YOU WILL BE FINE.
WE AREN’T GOING TO DEPORT YOU.
WE TRIED TO STOP THAT.
THERE IS STILL THE MESSAGE OUT
THERE.
YOU’LL HAVE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WANTS THEM HERE.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME.
IT IS SUCH AN INCONVENIENT SUCH
A BAD TIME FOR HIM TO HAVE DONE
THAT BECAUSE OF THE VERY ISSUES
WE’VE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
>> Harris: QUICKLY, IF YOU
START TO SEE THE NUMBERS OF
COVID GO UP FROM PEOPLE
CROSSING INTO YOUR STATE OR
WHATEVER THE SITUATION, DOES
THAT CHANGE THE IDEA ABOUT MASK
MANDATE AND THE REST?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I’M HOPING?
I HOPE WE MOVE BEYOND THAT.
THAT INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS OWNERS
CAN DECIDE.
THEY CAN HAVE MASKS.
INDIVIDUALS CAN MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES ABOUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO, THEIR HEALTH
STATUS, THEIR AGE, WHETHER THEY
HAVE RISK FACTORS.
ESPECIALLY AS THE VACCINE
BECOMES MORE PREVALENT I THINK
IT’S TIME FOR INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY AS OPPOSED TO
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT.
>> Harris: ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN